new york creates a lot of trash
every day nyc picks up twelve thousand
tons of refuse and recycling through two
thousand miles of city per day so how
does all this trash go from garbage bag
to its final destination i'm ed grayson
commissioner of new york city's
department of sanitation now trash
doesn't just walk onto a garbage truck
and today we're going to take you step
by step on how that happens this is the
journey of how one piece of trash goes
from here to here
[Music]
i just went to the guy on the corner got
my coffee cup i'm done with it 90 of the
time on that if you don't have some
place that's going to take it as paper
if you didn't have a way to find that
wax paper that's going to be garbage we
want you to source separate in your
house so you're going to have your
regular garbage you're going to have
your paper and you're going to have your
metal glass and plastics next our coffee
cup goes from bag to truck
we have a pretty large fleet we host
over 6 500 total pieces of fleet about
half of that is heavy fleet used for
refusing recycling and debris removal
we're talking about the iconic large
white 25-yard collection truck that
people see driving around our reloading
collecting trucks are
what's called a pusher packer there's a
piston inside the truck and it's pushing
back the whole time that clam sweeper
comes down and it sweeps what's inside
the hopper up into the body of the truck
that piston inside the truck is
compacting the garbage the entire time
and most of the trucks in new york city
are going to easily hold between 10 and
12 tons of garbage without even batting
an eye and every day those trucks
carrying those trash bags are
maintaining a unique route throughout
the city our coverage area is about 6
300 linear miles so on any given day of
the week we're trying to cover about 2
000 of those miles and to do that we're
going to dispatch about 7 100 routes per
week so a little over 1200 a day we run
a six-day collection cycle the city of
new york is five boroughs but it's 59
community boards inside the five
boroughs and dsny has a garage for each
of the 59 community boards our main goal
is to get the refusing recycling routes
scheduled between midnight so we'll
start on the overnight and 4 pm
this gives us 4 pm to the next midnight
to find out any places that for whatever
reason we had a service gap in whether
it was a block street you know police
activity you name it that was blocking
our ability to service that area or
service those block segments and then
what we use on the 4 pm to midnight
shift is going out there to
totally mop up what we didn't get on the
first two watches what we're definitely
trying to do is make sure that we're
routing efficiently that's the main goal
because we want to make sure that we're
always getting the latest set of gis
data seeing how the overlays of our gps
performance is doing to make sure that
we number one have every street routed
routed effectively routed efficiently so
we can complete our routes on time next
step
transfer station
[Music]
for the new york city department of
sanitation we have five transfer
stations four are marine transfer
stations where we bring it to the
station and then the final disposition
is going to go on a barge that takes it
to either a landfill operation and or
waste to energy facility and then lastly
our fifth operation is in the borough
staten island and that is a rail
transfer station a lot of people don't
realize none of the landfills are here
some of it goes up north to northern
parts of new york some of it goes down
the i-95 corridor so we're going to
jersey we're going to you know ohio
going to virginia and so what does that
mean for our bodega coffee cup our
bodega coffee cup is probably going to
end up in a landfill in nyc anywhere
from 60 percent to 70 of trash is still
going to landfills
[Music]
so
what exactly is the future of sanitation
how can we prevent more waste from going
into landfills one way is through
anaerobic digestion this is using
basically a giant stomach and you're
going to put your organic material in
there after taking this wet waste and
this wet organic waste and some food
scraps and some food organics and other
compostable organic material and they're
going to add it into basically a giant
digester which is full of microbes and
those microbes are going to break down
some of the other new emerging
technologies that are coming down the
pipe are wasted volumizers and waste
dehydrators and what they'll do is
they'll ring all the water out of it
does a couple things number one speeds
up the digestion of that to make it more
nutrient than compost and or takes up
some of the weight in some of the room
so you're getting a two-fold bang for
that you're getting less greenhouse
gases that could be emitted because it's
just not as much material and more
importantly better chance to turn it
into reusable compost depending on what
your next step is
[Music]
now there'll always be a role for the
sanitation department we're going to
come we're going to keep your streets
clean and we're going to come and get
you all those recyclables that are at
the curb we don't want to come pick up
your garbage we want to pick up all the
things you did right at the curb every
day